how do you describe what you do
so I'm a professional athlete and
yeah sponsored athlete as well in what
category so I compete in men's physique
which is a bodybuilding class and that
transitions from athletic look
um but as the years have gone on it's
it's got more and more
muscular should we say
what drives you to do what you do why do
you choose to do this sport that
involves starving yourself down to an
incredibly low body fat
that involves off Seasons you took an
entire off season where you didn't even
compete for basically a year and a half
in order to be able to come back
why why choose that spot
so for me just a bit of background about
myself
um I was all I was always brought up
around Sports I was very competitive
growing up I was football gymnastics and
swimming and golf and it was my life
that Competitive Edge I had an older
brother an older sister who I always
used to compete with at home it never
never stopped and basically when I came
into my teenage years around the age of
14 I started to develop a complex about
the way I looked a bit of um
body this morphew should we say and I
started to join a gym because for me I
thought
training my body making sure that I'm
got a six-pack looking good feeling good
they're all gonna help with confidence
just rolling it back a little bit there
why do you think that body dysmorphia
came from because we're basically the
same age yeah and you know we didn't
have the same levels of comparison
certainly at the age of 14 Facebook
didn't even exist no there was no
Instagram there was no YouTube really
true what what caused the onset of that
I think for me it's it's funny because
me and my siblings have spoke about this
before because we all had the same type
of complex but we don't know why we had
a great upbringing I didn't have a Far
Over figure in my life and didn't know
my my dad for about 10 years growing up
in that same period And so whether that
was a deciding factor
um we didn't have a lot of money all
that kind of we never went without we
just never had the best of the best and
but we had a brilliant upbringing should
we say it was not on the half you're
bringing
um but yeah I don't know we always just
felt there was something missing I
always and when I think when I was 14
obviously girls came on the scene and it
became more
I became more aware of myself I think up
until that point I was just so excited
on sports playing just being a kid and I
think at the age of 14 I had to start
work and I was pot watching at the age
of 14 waiting at the age of 40. was that
a contribute for paying for the house
and stuff for the family yep so I paid
rent
um
from the age of 14 I was 35 pounds and I
earned probably 50 and that was every
night I worked on a Saturday I did
removals uh Furniture removals on a
Sunday I did pot washing all day and
then yeah I mean we always take 35
pounds the moment I I got to 16 I was
paying 50 pounds so um okay yeah the
wage increases oh it did Hit me hard so
we had to um so I I didn't have an
option of going on to sixth form or
anything like that we I went straight
into an apprenticeship
um and yeah I learned the value of money
and hard work uh early on but yeah
whether that gave me a complex or not
when I was younger I don't know but from
when I was 14 I decided I needed to
change things I was I wouldn't say I was
overweight but I just I felt like I was
in my head and I was always looking
around and at school I never understood
why I was the guy who used to wear a
white T-shirt under his shirt wear a
jumper and a coat to try and hide
himself in the middle of summer and I
was like you're crazy but that was just
something I always did and never knew
why or or understood it so yeah so I
started training and I saw my body
changing quite quickly and yeah I became
obsessed with the gym and and trying to
learn how to
the nutrition learn my way around
nutrition what did you do as a young guy
who was trying to find his way in the
world yeah you know I think it was less
confusing when we were growing up than
it is now but still not totally like the
guardrails weren't exactly there given
the fact that you have this decade
without a father figure did you find
yourself trying to supplement that with
other male role models did you look up
to other people for inspiration where
did they come from yeah so my brother is
two years older than me and he was kind
of like the head of the house kind of he
was my sister's older as well and so I
kind of grew up a couple years older
than like with people older than me so
kind of bit of ahead of my time the time
I was 18 I was thinking about having my
own house my own business when really
shouldn't be thinking like that 18 you
should be still being a kid good on your
Lads holidays all that kind of stuff but
for me he was always a role model for me
but he went in the Army at 16 so he left
when I was 14 he left and that to me
felt like it's my time I need to to fill
his shoes and and grow up and stuff so
maybe that was
yeah forced me to be more
down another path and when I joined the
local gym it was a Backstreet
bodybuilding gym very hardcore and the
guys in there made me work for it but so
I was the little guy just walking around
the little teenager who was just thought
they were gonna I was gonna be gone in
six months but are you in the truster I
earned their respect from training every
day there
um and yeah they took me under their
wing and that's how I fell into
bodybuilding and I used to watch them
train him
I'm not trying to be super heavyweight
bodybuilders 350 pound guys massive
massive weights and I always loved their
dedication and I always resonated with
that because of that the sports side of
me with the competing side sorry so when
competing came up and they said why
don't you try it I was looking at
thinking I don't have the confidence to
take my top off and step on stage there
was an apprentice plumber working on
site I never used to do my hair I would
never take my top off in a million years
but there was something telling me to
face my fears there was something saying
step out your comfort zone and see if
you can do what these guys all around
you every day are doing
um and that was doing a bodybuilding
show dieting down and I just I loved I I
wasn't inspired by the the size of him
I was just um
inspired by the way they they lived
their life how how regimented they were
how dedicated they were how competitive
they were how they had a goal and for me
I wanted to try it just once and that
was my goal just to try it once so I
didn't tell anybody just in case I uh I
backed out the last minute but I started
dieting alongside these guys for this
show and I saw uh this show came up and
it was the closest to me because
it was only like an hour and a half down
the road lemington spa and I didn't
realize but this show was a national
qualifier it was a big show but I just
assumed it was a small Regional show and
then yeah dieted down didn't tell
anybody registered the night before and
I got down there on the day and I was
like this backstage shaking like mad I
was like what am I doing what the hell
am I doing like I'm a plumber I should
not be doing this and then yeah yeah
stepped on stage and I don't know what
it was I became somebody else my Alter
Ego came out I was walking on stage like
this and the moment the lights hit me
and I came out onto stage I was like no
you've done all the hard work you
deserve to be here now it's time to
battle and that's how I took it it was
like it was a sport and the feeling of
winning and obviously you won that first
show yeah yeah and that Elation of of
getting first place and then I just yeah
unbelievable do you think that your
sport could have been replaced by
basically anything else like it was it
it seems to me like it's competition
it's hard work it's being disciplined
it's having a goal and working toward it
it doesn't really seem like
it's that much about the bodybuilding
itself it's about pushing yourself yeah
I think so but because I I was instilled
to work constantly work
the the sports I was doing at the time
was like Golf and I got down to the end
of scratch handicap and those type of
sports were were taking four or five
hours out of the day which for me was my
working day whereas training was a
necessity for me because I needed to
transform my physique and that's what
helped with my self-confidence so that
wasn't an option not to train so if I
was to do a sport it would have been
bodybuilding and another sport whereas
bodybuilding fell into both categories I
could keep my confidence and
and yeah my self-confidence all but at
the same time still have that
competitive drive at something we spoke
before we got started about the um
challenges that you face if you become
too obsessive with tracking now whether
you're looking at wearables whether
you're looking at the Quantified Self
movement whether you're looking at
getting blood panels done yeah uh
biohacking
I imagine that the level that you're
performing at which is the biggest in
the world there's only one title that
you haven't won yet am I right saying
yeah which is the the Olympia the Mr
Olympia yeah so there is one title left
basically on everything on the planet
that you haven't yet got yes so you have
probably worked with the best coaches in
terms of training in terms of posing in
terms of nutrition in terms of sleep
recovery rest mindset all that stuff yes
which also probably will have opened up
access to all manner of Quantified Self
ideas and stuff
what has your journey been going from
um eating to feel training to feel
obsessive tracking uh using the
wearables not using the wearables uh and
what are the lessons that you've taken
away from that
yeah so so for me when I started
obviously competing in the early days
um it was just about the enjoyment of it
and for self-confidence it wasn't about
um building a career out of it I didn't
realize I could I could build a career
from it and I just did it for the
enjoyment and it kept me on a level
where I was happy so while I well whilst
ever I was in prep and enjoying the
whole process of training and just
having that accountability every day
I was happy and my best results and the
the growth of of my career happened so
fast when I was in that state of mind
and again if you look back at them I was
very relaxed in how I trained so it was
all about how I feel how I pump up my
strength tiredness all these basic
things on how I feel just being at one
with myself like looking in the mirror
thinking right things need to change I
need to work on this I'm not feeling
great today do I need more sleep
um right I'm not feeling strong we're
going to back off the heavy weight sets
we're going to look for more time on
detention or more volume sets just to go
off how I feel but as I grew and got
more and more
um more competitive in in the
bodybuilding career and winning more
titles
the teams came on teams wanted to help
they wanted to know your body fat they
wanted to know all these other things
and I let them come on and it became I
don't know it it was unenjoyable for me
because it was taken away why I started
it and why I did it which was again for
self-confidence and the enjoyment of it
and every day we're waking up and we
were tracking this we were weighing this
and it just it took it away for me and
it just became monotonous and a job for
me and I'm obsessed with bodybuilding I
love it but it's a lifestyle 365 days a
year I've done this for the last 20
years and I enjoy it but when I went
through that stage I lost the enjoyment
and that for me was a big thing and if
you look over my career and my play-ins
I had a two-year lull
um and it was because of that because I
just I was answering to other people I
lost confidence in myself because I was
thinking I don't know the answer to this
or do I need to change this what do I
take this food out or oh no there's a
variable here what do I do whereas
normal normally and now I just adapt
accordingly because I know my body and
as I'm getting older my metabolism is
changing but that's the beauty of
bodybuilding like everything changes
from time to time the interesting thing
that I've been playing with as well
since starting doing this show
you start off doing something that you
love right and you end up being
competence at it or semi-competent at it
and then you start to work a little bit
harder and you think wow I'm accruing
more gains than I feel like I should be
you know your first show you shouldn't
have won your first show like most
people don't by definition
and then you go okay well I'm going to
lean into this more and then as you said
you get the opportunity maybe I could
turn this into a profession maybe I
could start to labor around this
but one of the quickest ways that you
can destroy your love for something is
to turn it into a labor 100 and most of
the people from the outside this is
there's a concept called ikigai right
which is your calling in life it's at
the intersection of uh what you're good
at what Society needs what you can be
paid for and what you love to do right
so you can imagine you've got this Venn
diagram in right in the middle that's
where your highest point of contribution
is between all of those things
presumably because you need to be
supported by it
most people that start doing something
that they absolutely love they're a
painter they play the guitar to
themselves they do whatever don't
realize
what on the other side of turning that
into a job would perhaps cause a lot of
the things that they love about their
love to fall away yeah and all of these
unseen costs to come through all of the
travel all of the additional time away
from friends and family the obligations
that you need to do for people like
gymshark for your supplement company etc
etc yeah um those start to stack up
because you go I'm not I'm no longer
being supported by being a plumber by
being on site by doing these things yeah
and then on top of that you have like
you have the existential pain of well if
I fail when it's just my thing on the
side it doesn't matter I'm still a
plumber I'm still a father I'm still a
friend I'm still a whatever yeah but if
I am my Pursuit yeah and I fail at my
Pursuit yeah that means that I am a
failure right there is no more
existential distance between what you
how you show up in the world in your
chosen Pursuit yeah and who you are yeah
and
that that pressure for a lot of people
is really crippling yeah and it's it's
something that getting through it
it seems like it is was a challenge for
you yeah it was and the thing is when we
talk about training as well you know
even down to the train aspect of it a
lot of people now have log books and
they track everything which if that
works for that individual I'm all for it
I think fantastic and if you enjoy that
process but I'm on the other side of it
I'm very sporadic I like to to go in and
how it feels on the day and I know how
to push my body through its limits and
to its limits so for me
I've learned that over the years and
whenever I try to implement something
like that too much structure I lose that
enjoyment which I'm actually being
counterproductive because for me that's
just how I've always worked in business
and I'm a lot more
more productive now when I free flow and
some people I've spoken to people who
are so anal and about that they just
can't comprehend it but it works yeah
but for me the opposite way around I
can't comprehend that so I come from a
productivity background when we first
started this podcast a lot of it was
about productivity because I was I was
adamant that the right note-taking app
and external brain system would fix all
of my problems okay spoiler alert it
didn't but
I tried really really hard to have this
perfect note-taking system and it would
all be nested and the notion database
would be updating all this stuff and I
would use my getting things done to-do
list reminders yeah
and I found it stressful I found it very
arduous to try and construct my life
using this
um and now I'm looking at my notes in
Front of Me 2 563 notes which we've got
on on Apple notes which is what we use
the most basic [__] thing that my mum
probably uses to remind herself of her
shopping my point being that whatever
the system is that you get into using
yeah has to work for you and
trying to follow on from someone else's
prescription the model of this is how
it's supposed to work
it's very easy especially in 2023 to say
well going more Quantified going more
aggressive with your tracking especially
stuff like uh heavy app
um and all of these weight tracking apps
they'll do your like poundage across an
entire workout across a week about rpes
you can do drops you can add everything
in Right Time dress periods for some
people that's great for other people
that's not but don't you thinking
especially with bodyguin there's so many
variables there's too many variables
that that
can change from from day to day so when
people track I think how can you track
like so specific because if you've had
eight hours sleep one day if you had 10
hours another day that two hours
difference in sleep will make a huge
difference for me it does I know is so I
I can what do you try and get in terms
of sleep tonight
I've got a two-year-old right right out
of the window okay I would love eight
hours but now I'm up at four or four
most mornings uh doing our work and then
I I do my cardio my fastest cardio after
half past five and then the house is
awake from six so okay yeah it's a crazy
morning right we'll go into that yeah
yeah yeah so one of the things I'm
interested in you know you are
getting toward like the peak of your
career now with regards to marrying
business still doing the thing that got
you famous yeah all of your obligations
you're living in the UK which
is a great country but does have a
little bit of a cap in terms of the
ceiling of success right you are far and
away probably the best known physique
competitor coming out of the UK yeah how
have you managed to keep your goals
growing with you yeah given the fact
that you're outstripping pretty much all
of your competition the reason I say
this is that there will be a lot of
people listening by definition they're
listening to this kind of a podcast that
means that they're already selected out
into the top 0.1 percent of people
thinking about personal development
thinking about improving themselves yeah
how can someone how did you and how can
someone who doesn't necessarily have
that
um community of competitors and
encouragement around them wherever they
live yeah continue to push themselves as
their goals get bigger as they progress
that's a hard question how did you do it
so why were you so driven given the fact
that you kept on beating everybody why
were you so driven so for me I was
always driven to be number one in the
world and until I would get that title
until I've won the Olympia in my eyes
I've not I'm not the best in the world
I'm not I've not achieved what I've set
out to achieve so everything I've ever
set out to achieve in this industry I've
achieved so far other than the Olympia
so my goal was always every show I've
ever done to never do a lesser show in
Prestige so that was how I grew quite
quickly because I was very strategic on
in in the the shows I did I did my
research before and I wanted to be known
straight to I wanted to go against the
best straightaway I wasn't someone who
wanted to just make the numbers up or
have an easy qualification easy route to
Olympia I wanted to go against the best
as quick as possible to know my worth
and to know if I'm good enough to be up
there because again I want to win shows
I don't want to be there just to make
the numbers up and that always drove me
so I was very fortunate earlier on I was
like say I was the first pro from the UK
for a hell first pro from Europe held
that for five six years before anyone
else who was me against the Americans
for so long and that was just driving
forcing itself I felt like I had the UK
behind me like pushing me and pushing
pressures and expectations of an entire
nation very good but it was phenomenal I
loved it and even now I still have that
drive
um but I'm realistic because
I have other obligations with family now
and I know I need to provide for them
and I know I need to
um always be there for them I don't want
to be a selfish dad I want to be the
best
um husband I can to my wife so things
change along the way and it has become
so much harder now but if I want it
which I do I will I'll keep going and
just keep finding a route and that's how
I liked it I don't overthink it I need
to be ready in six weeks or seven weeks
time for my next show it's not been
announced yet the things I'm doing now
I've got five businesses and obviously a
young family I've got my wife who's
pregnant who's doing three months and
I'm doing something huge project to do
which I can't talk about there is so
much at stake here I know what it is I
know I know what the project is it's
pretty cool but I thrive off it I
absolutely love it and if if I didn't
have that I would go in saying that I've
always worked at such a high capacity
because it's the only way I know how I
think because of that work ethic being
in still from the age of 14. if I get
too complacent I get I get stuck I lose
my head and I need to be constant what
happens if it's three years from now and
you still haven't won Mr Olympia
oh that's a good question it's hard to
say because people assume I'm older than
I am because one because I talk I'm very
monotonous and old boy
but two because I've been in in the
industry so long we were talking before
I had a guy yesterday called to me and
say oh I was looking at your front cover
magazines for muscle and fitness in 2009
wow 14 years ago like and I remember
that like it was yesterday and it's just
crazy to think but I was very successful
in my early days so from 1890 and I came
onto the scene so now I'm competing
against guys who are still two three
years older than me winning the Olympia
so I don't want to be a guy who stuck
around thank God he's still here after
like 15 years but at the same time
whilst never I've still got that drive
and that hunger and that passion for
that that first place I'll keep go I'll
keep going
um so if it gets if it gets to that
stage if you're like
I'm now 38 39 40 41. then you how how
difficult is it going to be for you to
let that go if you haven't won that
title so me Ross actually have actually
spoke in detail about this because that
is my fear I'll admit this now is
I don't know because competing satisfies
that that competitive side of me I don't
know what I'll do when it's over because
I never did it for the fame or for the
popularity or anything like that it was
always about
yeah satisfying that hunger for
competitiveness so
when that stops and my wife said the
same you need to start to think about it
now and start to address it because yeah
I tried to have a year out like say last
year and the reason I had that year out
was that I was thinking it's time for me
to stop or to to kind of because we had
a child on the way and all that kind of
stuff and I got five businesses to run I
was trying to
feel that competitive
void with businesses and trying to keep
me busy that's a but I couldn't like I I
just love competing I love being in that
regimented state and that that fire to
compete against other athletes it just
yeah I'm not sure what I'm going to do
to be honest I think that one of the
best examples of this which I always use
is Eddie Hall right so you know Eddie
gets very close to winning world's
strongest man he doesn't he's sort of
pipped at the Post Yeah and then he does
and he's there stood with this
trophy in his hand and he's crying for
his grandma I think that's recently
passed away uh and he retires he retires
there and then and
I don't know man I I would like to think
that when you do end up winning that
trophy you should be able to go out with
a lot of Grace and go okay like what's
the next challenge the problem again for
me though so it's in trouble that's for
me I would be happy to win people say
here but would you would you you'd want
to start a legacy and would you want to
win it again and again I wouldn't now
for me once I've achieved like I said
I've won every show I've worn I have no
desire to go back and win that again
even though they are really prestigious
shows it's another year on you'd get the
popularity you get the prize money you'd
get all of that with with win that show
again but for me
I've done that it's in the past I don't
have that same drive for that show like
the Arnold Classics so why did you do
three Arnold Classics because you say
you don't you want to do a show that
you've done because I want I wanted to
be the first one in the UK I want to be
the first in Europe and the first in the
USA so that was three different Arnold
Classics in three different continents
what a country sorry which no one else
has done okay let's say you are someone
who has spent the last 20 years focusing
on training especially for hypertrophy
you are someone that has won pretty much
every single title on the planet
you have 10 exercises that you can do
for the rest of your life in order to
maintain as good of a physique as you
can
what are they and why
ten that's very specific ten I just
figured I just figured that that would
be enough for you to get each different
muscle group right okay so what are the
what are the longest levers that you can
pull when it comes to maintaining size
or increasing size of obviously compound
list so you're looking at your deadlifts
uh your bench press
um and your squats they're always good
again these are things that I have had
to adapt over the years because of um
injuries and things training silly when
I was younger okay there's three there's
three there
um hanging leg raise for core it's one
of the hardest mid-sections if you do it
properly I think it's one of the hardest
uh mid-section exercises but it's
phenomenal for your transverse abdomenes
your upper and lower abdominals
everything just it's a great
I feel like that was something that
helped me build my my midsection you've
got one of the like acclaimed best
midsections in all of Fitness what are
the cues that people get wrong when
they're doing hanging leg roses so the
create momentum the swing which um
I think that's a bit to do CrossFit with
this Kip in Malarkey and momentum stuff
that that came into play a fair few
years ago but
um yeah I think swinging um I think
using the hip flexors instead of the the
midsection how do you know if you're
doing that you'll feel it you'll feel it
down your quads
um what's the cue someone's doing a
someone's listening to this hanging from
a bar right now what is the cue for them
to go from I'm hanging straight to I'm
doing a leg raise
that makes it work appropriately so is
it tucking the hips in and making sure
you're Contracting you're up and lower
abdominals before anything else so it's
always keeping them fully contracted
Minds multiple connection is is a huge
thing I believe in that so much yeah
Mike Thurston does the same yeah and the
thing is the last few years I've done
that so much more now as I've got older
and more mature I'm not just trying to
lift heavy weight and trying to Ego lift
and since I've done that the muscle
maturity and how my body's developed
it's just exponential I just wish I'd
done it five six years ago
um so yeah so I think that's very
important mind to muscle connection with
hanging leg raises you're going to an L
are you going up to touch the bar so
either so I used to do all the way to
the top
um but I alternate now so I just do a
bit of both
um I think there's there's a place for
both of them but I think that when you
go past a certain point you are
recruiting all the muscle groups and so
if you want to just isolate your
midsection just go to 90 degrees how do
you do Progressive overload on that or
do you
you or you could add weights to you do
you I don't personally because I was
obsessed with my midsection girl or as
you say Rob Richards was the guy who got
me obsessed with it so I wanted to be on
the front covers like Rob was I you see
all the magazines and I
try to treat my midsection like any
other muscle but some a lot of people
think with the midsection you should um
training 30 minutes after every session
or why every other muscle part we train
we train to break the muscle fibers down
heavy a lot of load we break the most
followers we'll let them recover two
three four days before we hit him again
and that's how I
looked and viewed my midsection so I'd
give them two full hour sessions with a
three to four day rest between and had
the six to eight rep range really heavy
the thing with that I start to develop
really chunky ABS blocky ABS but in the
end it started to look a bit distended
because I'd gone too far with it and I
was causing so many back problems had
slipped discs from it and basically it's
because I was too front heavy too front
strong so it took a lot of years to
start having to uh hyper extend for
every
crunch I did they said I had to do two
hyper extensions wow so yeah it was you
needed to compensate for all of that
anterior strength that you developed and
so now I don't tend to go too heavy and
we do a lot of own body weight stuff
okay cool so you've got four you've got
squat bench deadlift yeah okay hanging
leg raises six more slots to keep your
body
uh so so I'll go with uh some isolation
work so we'll we'll probably go with
like an incline dumbbell chest just
because
um you can do very a lot of different
variations on that but I think it's
great for development
um
shoulders aren't getting much work at
the moment
all right shoulder press we'll go with a
dumbbell shoulder press because it's
great for isolation unilateral
um and that's quite important
um obviously
so we need to do some hamstring work so
we would do
I would
I would say stiff like deadlift but now
we I think if we're going to try and
create some growth I think we're gonna
go for like a lion hamstring curl heavy
you prefer a lying to a seated
I do yes
um yeah I do but I don't know if that's
down to the fact I just get better
contraction off that I think it's
personal preference
um in my eyes like I've always said that
with any type of exercises if you feel
an exercise more than another stick with
it Go With It do the extra sets and Reps
on that particular exercise because
that's where you're going to get the
most out of it if you're doing an
exercise because someone else has told
you to do it and you're not getting that
my internal connection or you're not
revealing it there's no point and that's
that's what I love about bodybuilding as
well nutrition and training you adapt it
to you it's it's an individual sport you
can have people around you supporting it
but your metabolism and the way you
train the way you eat it all falls on
you so learn the body yourself and adapt
as you go okay three left what have you
got
I've lost where we are now um squat
bench deadlift hanging leg raise uh
incline chest press with dumbbells
shoulder press seated car phrase seated
calf raise oh so you want to get the
Soleus moving yeah we'll get them in
okay David okay we'll cover them and
then um two left we need overhead tricep
extension rope
pivoted from the bottom of a pulley yeah
right okay yeah what are the cues that
people get wrong there because this is a
something that I absolutely love to do
but where do people go wrong quite
mechanically quite a complex movement
yeah I think you can go too heavy too
soon and start recruiting and start yeah
pulling I don't know with the shoulder I
think it's it's important to lock your
elbows in a fixed position as well as
the shoulder make sure there's no
movement there I like to elongate and
stretch it out and not a lot of people
go too far with it but I like to
overextend slightly to get a full
stretch
um and a full contraction at the top
um online
we need biceps down then we've got
everything then what's your number one
bicep exercise
what is my number one box you know what
I'm going to say I'm going to say it um
this is a bit of an outward one this
because I've done loads of them today is
um pull-ups close grip pull-ups I know
it's a back workout but your secondary
muscle is bicep and the contraction I
get off that for my bicep every week I
hit them I always want to bring my back
up anyway so it's an excuse to just hit
the back as well but I think that's a
great
overall exercise given the fact that
you've added deadlifts in what is it
that you're finding as a physique
competitor that first off isn't
massively judged on your legs and
secondly wants a narrow torso
okay why would you put deadlift into
that kind of a workout so I've never
believed this with I don't know if
scientifically this is right but we've
deadlifted I've never I used to deadlift
every week I don't so much now do a lot
more isolation on hyper extensions again
because I get a better contraction I do
hypers I prefer to deadlift but I do
hypers mainly but with a deadlift
um obviously recruits near off every
muscle in the in the body so it's great
for for an overall workout but
um I've lost my train of thought well
what were we saying why are you using
deadlifts given that you want to have a
small waist yeah like I say because I
train my midsection the way I do I do a
lot of ice attention in the morning
um
so it's basically all about ISO holds so
you breathe in fully breathe in with you
exhale every bit of air out of the body
and you crunch your abs as hard as you
can for three seconds and then standing
up standing up yeah you can do that with
any muscle part so I it's the most
monotonous thing a bodybuilder can do
but it's one of the best things for for
muscle control for getting everything
tight for condition
I challenge anybody to do this so do
we'll keep it simple three
three from the front three from the size
you've got three on the bleaks on either
side so you've got so you inhale
hands of yet as you come down you crunch
you exhale every bit of air out you
crunch and hold it for three seconds as
hard as you can it's good to have your
top off because you need to seriously
tense do it again
and crunch try and do that 10 times and
then go to the side and then crunch down
hold and they do that 10 times and they
do that 10 times have 30 seconds rest go
again and then go again I do it five
rounds and you're literally dripping wet
through and the blood volume you get in
your midsection is insane so you can do
that with like um with your biceps or
between exercises so if you're doing um
yeah like a bicep curl you can
straighten you hold your pose a double
bicep and you hold you squeeze your
midsection you squeeze it your biceps as
hard as you can for 20 seconds say you
come out and you go straight back into
your working set it is brutal but if you
ever see on a bodybuilding stage when
when people are out there shaking
because they've got no connection
they've got no control over their biceps
that's why that happens yeah yeah
there's also there's other factors what
can happen dehydrated they're tired
et cetera et cetera nine times out of
ten that will be down to the fact
they've not done any ISO holes or
they've not took the time with their
posing to practice the posing
um and that's something I always pride
in myself and I remember the first few
shows I did on the Olympia stage we're
all we're all back um hitting from the
back and the guys are going like Ryan
what you know how are you holding that
how are you holding that because they're
all everyone's shaking and it's because
eight weeks out from any show 30 minutes
after my fasted cardio I'll do ISO holds
with every every pose I have to do and
every muscle group so it's it's
horrendous but these are the things that
people don't see these are like so when
you look at bodybuilding oh yeah you eat
some meals and you train uh twice a day
but it's the the little things it's the
what I've I'm I obsess over because it's
okay having a great work ethic like in
the gym or having the discipline to eat
your six meals and and not cheat
but it's also the other bits of
presentation which is so important
what's your morning routine take me
through it from waking up what time what
do you do what are you eating what are
you drinking what movements are you
going through yeah so typically around
five o'clock we get up
um I do a black coffee I'll go down I'll
have uh eaas and L-Carnitine and that's
like 15 minutes before I go and do my
oral L-Carnitine are injected oral yep
yeah oral through liquid liquid form and
then 15 minutes after that I'll go and
do an hour faster cardio so 30 minute
cross trainer 30 minute incline walk
what sort of heart rate is on to
again I don't look at that now that
that's I'm very basic in that it's a low
intensity it's nothing to do something
that way I'll do 30 minute call work or
um let's have a 30 minute call work or
30 minute uh stretch Mobility work after
that hour
um and then it's 30 minutes uh posing so
you're doing what time is it now so that
is seven o'clock ish half seven wow okay
so it's a very regimented morning yeah
yeah okay seven o'clock yeah so then
half seven I'll go in I'll have
yeah massive breakfast but uh to most
most people it's massive but for me it's
it's nothing but what does that
typically consist of so I'll always make
sure uh my first meal has every source
of approach so we've got a good um
source of protein bioavailable protein
we've got so like a whey protein or away
isolate we've got complex carbs so
oatmeal
um we've got essential fats through
almond butter or almond flakes we've got
blueberries antioxidants uh are you
blending all this together you're eating
it separately no I eat it all together
in I don't blend it we cook it I put the
protein in I let the I cook it all first
let it cool down then put the protein in
not to degenerate it too much yep okay
and then yeah I'll take my multivits um
so we've got Multiverse CLA uh Amigas
all that kind of stuff
um around yeah my meal we're now at what
8 30. eight o'clock yeah around eight
o'clock okay day's about to begin yeah
and then obviously my son's ready to he
has breakfast with me so I'll make these
breakfast at the same time
um I've changed his nappy twice by then
okay does that get added into the
workout as well yeah it's horrendous
fantastic
um and then yeah we get him ready um and
then yeah I start my working day so dude
I mean
just that morning you mentioned before
we got started I trained three times a
day you know I I'm good friends with a
bunch of CrossFit athletes and they're
known for training slash over training
yeah
I think from the outside especially the
world of physique yeah but also
bodybuilding
the volume of training is something that
people don't really get to see and part
of that is it doesn't translate very
well on video yeah you know like
understand it because no one's going to
show five or six sets of 12 on one
exercise then five or six sets of twelve
on another exercise whereas everybody
knows what a 20 minute Imam of 30
minutes of money structural work is
think CrossFit particularly is a sport
or a training methodology that is
designed
to look good yeah on video you know it's
quite compelling it's varied it's high
intensity uh bodybuilding is a bit more
monotonous which makes it less exciting
um I think the same thing's true of
footballers as well then
the difficulty of training that
footballers go through specifically
is something that nobody thinks about
like you think about boxes uh you know
even it's a tennis players golfers you
think about the amount of time they
spend
so to me when you think about football
it's given that it's the most popular
sport on the planet I just don't hold
them in the same reverence you know I
don't think that the hard workers I'm
sure that the tons and tons and tons of
hard workers look at Ronaldo with his
top off insane yeah
but I still don't hold them in that same
way do you know what I mean no 100 but
then obviously what we talk about just
to give you insight about my working day
as well so I eat every two hours so I
have to cook at least six meals a day so
in that time I have three chicken
breasts or
and a four chicken breast in about four
chicken breasts two salmon fillets two
fillet steaks a day four eggs a day all
with rice white potato eggs
oats uh so much veg so I have to prep
all that that straight after my morning
you're doing that you haven't got
somebody that comes in you're not just
paying a chef to come and do this for
you so I did that for about three months
and I just couldn't get my head around
someone else doing my work for me and I
just because I need to know when I step
on stage every part of my prep and every
part of my 365 days
of the Year going into that show I know
exactly what I've put into being under
your control yes and that even my wife
bless her we had this conversation last
week she tried to shorten my dayblet so
whilst I was she was working out right
he must be nearly 15 minutes from fish
you start to make my breakfast and she
put it in the microwave ready so all I
had to do was press it on but I couldn't
get my head around it because I was like
are you sure it's only 120 grams in that
you sure there's only 20 grams of
almonds and it's ridiculous but I just
feel comfortable yeah I don't make a
scene or anything it's just what I've
always done quietly chug on yeah get it
done and when people talk about um like
if you see a body and they get you get
this misconception and it's it's
horrible where people are like oh you're
living out your Tupperware and you make
a big scene of it yeah you've got your
fishing license I've managed to do that
for for 20 years now and I've never made
it like I can still socialize my friends
still go out at night we go to
restaurants if I can't eat what nine
times out of ten I can eat in every
restaurant you just ask for a plane
steak or a plain chicken breast jacket
potato some mixed casual mixed salad
it's easy so when they say I can't have
that I can't eat any of any of this
because it's not on prep you can of
course you can you just have to adapt
and it's it's how much you want to live
in normal society and be a bodybuilder
which don't typically go hand in hand
but I go on nights out I'll nip out to
my car quickly eat my meal come back in
the time it takes to go to the toilet so
people don't even know about my son's
birthday really sad two two weeks out
from the Olympia everyone's celebrating
in this Pub
um
yeah the garden pool and yeah just kept
nipping off every two hours into my car
to eat my meals back in no one even knew
look I'm going to get a drink it's like
being uh it's like being a closet drug
addict yeah but yours is protein instead
of heroin or something went to watch
Cree three last week with my
brother-in-law and that's how sniffing
the toilet straight out the fire exit
leave a meal of the car parked straight
back in didn't even no one even knew you
don't have to make a scene of it it's
just part and parcel of what I do and
it's just became the norm now but but
yeah just to follow on from the Working
Day and then I get into my emails like I
say I've got five businesses to run so
I've got property developing got
clothing company uh got a coaching
company
um blood lab which is
um a healthcare clinic company and then
rjt limited which is all my sponsors and
obligations there so we address where
can people go if they want to get blood
work done in the UK so it's called the
blood lab if you look on Instagram
you'll see but we have pop-up clinics
all over the UK Scotland Ireland so we
have about 40 to 50 clinics running
through the year and then we've got a
full-time HQ which I've just built in
hail Manchester so that's open 24 7.
um with
we've got over 20 phlebotomists now
we've got four so you have to go to to
the website book on yeah but you have to
go in terms of getting a blood draw it's
not like in the US where you can go to
the lab Co-op or the local places that
can take the blood and send it to you
yeah so you can have uh you can have it
done at your house we can send people
out to you so we we've partnered with
randox now so huge huge company who
actually can come to your door take your
blood work or you can do it yourself and
send it off we live yeah they'll
obviously not do it yourself but careful
about this dude right okay okay okay
yeah so when it comes home what's the
website if people want to get blood work
in the UK so yeah the bloodlab.co.uk
um go on to there and like you'll see we
do everything now so we do ECGs
echocardiograms um we do minor surgeries
trt HRT
um you're like a British Derek from more
plates more dates so yeah we're doing a
bit I'm still learning all this side of
it this is something as I've got older
I've talked more pride in um like my
blood work and that sort of thing
um talk to me about I mean if you you
have access to these Bloods what sort of
numbers do your test levels and
everything else get down to as you're
right at the bottom end of prep just how
ugly does that look well attend so this
is the thing as well I never look at
them whilst I'm in prep so I've got I've
put my my faith and trust into my doctor
which I I've worked with I met him on a
gym shark event in Australia would you
believe and we came came back and we
started working together and I just said
to him look I don't need to know that as
long as I'm healthy and I need know
where I need to be
don't again you know I said to you about
I don't want to concern myself with
numbers and analytics is what I want to
just unless I'm outside of range and
there's something really concerning just
yeah crack on but does he tell you
afterwards have you seen what it looks
like afterwards uh yeah it's very low
right almost admit with the body fat
being solo as well that is uh yeah it's
pretty low but it's just
within I'd say five or six weeks of
coming off the show getting my body fat
back up just easing off training and all
that kind of stuff a little bit less
stress yeah we're normally back into
where we need to be in
um that's why I kind of towards the end
the last few years I've only ever done
one show a year because of how taxing it
is on the body
um I used to live and breathe and it was
just the norm I used to love it but
obviously with having a family now and I
can't be selfish 365 days a year so for
me I just I have to think of them more
as well
given the fact that you've got this
massive Instagram people have been
following you for decades based on the
way that you look yeah do you have any
desire to start serving the world Beyond
just the Skin Deep way that you show up
have you got a plan for that moving
forward to actually add value Beyond
simply being a visual inspiration yeah
well so again so for me that was never
my intention to be front of house and to
I was always someone who liked to work
in the background and be an underdog you
know whether it was your intention or
not that's what's ended up happening
yeah you wouldn't believe it but um I
would love to do something to help
others and with the blood for me with
the blood lab I know it's a bit cliche
but that for me seems like I'm starting
to to transition more because the amount
of people with help now and the amount
of people educating because our it
started off as a bodybuilding like
filled with the blood work but we've now
gone further afield it's now mainstream
we're going corporate with it and
everything and it's growing at such a
level but it's just educating people
more around health and that's something
yeah that I've prided myself in so I
think without even consciously knowing
it that's the way where I'm going now uh
with a lot of things and the exciting
project that I'm building at the minute
that's that's a huge step in that
direction
um and it might be my retirement should
we say it might be my way of that
transition that might fill that Voyage
should we say with with competing
given the fact that you've spent so much
time up front being a competitor
how is that informing the way that you
show up as a father you've mentioned
that you've got a young son who is just
now going to be starting to ask
questions you know wanting to do things
maybe even looking at hobbies and you
know going into gym every morning Daddy
gym
I'll be back in an hour okay so what are
the values that you hope that you
instill into your son and what are the
things as well that you hope that you
don't given you know the 10-year absence
that you had of a father figure so that
is the reason I want to be the best at
in the world because of me not having
that when I was younger
um so that is my number one priority now
people say oh is that why you you
probably won't win the Olympia have you
lost that drive but I think the opposite
I want to prove to people and I want to
prove to my son like he's massive
motivation for me he's my driving force
to be able to provide for him for him to
be proud of me he was he was at the the
seat one I'm gonna actually emotional
talking about 1A
um at the Arnold Classic which meant he
was behind the head George which every
person who loves bodybuilding would want
to sit there I had my son who was one
years old sitting out I pulled every
string I could to have him sat there
because I wanted him to see his his dad
and to be proud of proud of him it's a
winner in front of him and stuff so he's
been a big driving force for me to carry
on and to keep getting better for him
personally and with the businesses and
all that kind of stuff one of the
business is in his name so he doesn't
know it he's the director and he it will
be his company youngest director in the
UK exactly so it's called Alta which is
Alfie Lewis Terry Aesthetics so for me
these are all things which I never had
and I've told you about
growing up with with we wouldn't have a
lot of money I was from the age of 14 I
was told I had to work and I was
instilled that hard work and yeah there
was times where we never had the best
things we never went without but we
appreciated money and we yeah we never
had the big holidays all that kind of
stuff so this is something I want to be
able to to give my son to have the life
I didn't have but at the same time I've
said to my wife please don't let me get
carried away just because we've done
well and we're financially okay now that
he doesn't appreciate the value of so
this is the next question I've got for
you mate how is it
given the fact that you have managed to
be an incredible success
in spite
because of the limitations and the
challenges that you had to face yeah
you want to pay forward your success to
give your kid the chances you never kids
that you that and the future yeah the
future one
um the chances that you never had the
opportunities you never had the quality
of life that you never had
and yet
both of us the things that we went
through when we were kids have driven us
to do things that in retrospect are
incredibly proud of yeah and very well
may not have achieved had we not have
had those setbacks that's very true how
I mean you know
this is a perennial question but how are
you balancing the difference between
wanting to give your child love and give
your child challenges yeah this is this
is a great this is a great topic if this
is something me and my wife need to sit
down and talk more about because
I am fearful of that like I said I want
to spoil my son yes I want to spoil my
son because I want
yeah I want him to be happy I wanted to
but at the same time I still want him to
be even to the point where this is going
to sound a bit wrong now but he's in
private school now or he only goes twice
twice a week he's only two years old but
I'm contemplating taking him out of
private school although I want him to
have the best start in life and the best
education life
I don't want him like you said the
Silver Spoon like I don't want him to
think that's the norm because he's going
to school with people who turn up in
helicopters and like Bentleys and and
I'm thinking I didn't have any of this
and I I've done okay and I and now I
wise look to the world a lot quicker and
it's in its harsh world and I don't want
him to be Molly coddled and he is being
to some degree with
with my wife and I love her so much for
it because she she cares for him so much
and it yeah he couldn't ask for a better
Mum but at the same time I am fearful
that he yeah he won't
be ready for the big wild world he's
gonna be exposed to those difficulties
man 100 I mean this is something that I
think about so much especially you know
I flew back from the US this morning
landed this morning
um the class system in the UK is very
rigid you know um America still has this
very fluid sort of working to middle and
then middle to upper class system I have
bags of friends in the US all of my
richest friends are American right all
of them yeah and the homeschooling their
kids paying tutors to come around to
school like it but they come from
backgrounds as poor as mine and yours
yeah but they don't have that sort of
glass ceiling rigid class structure
thing that plays on top of them
I feel it as well with me and I can't
wait to be a dad you know like when the
time's right for me
um but I think about that too how am I
going to be able to give the challenges
that I need to to my kids
to make them sufficiently resilient
because I know how much I value that in
myself yeah whilst not making their life
unnecessarily hard yeah uh it's very
they're very difficult there's so many
variables with that as well like for
instance we we've got like a we've had
to sit down as parents I think parenting
is so hard and you don't understand it
until you're like you're in a month
stand you're actually going through it
we were getting to a point where I was
conscious of this and my wife wasn't so
she was given everything he wanted all
that kind of I was the opposite because
I could see that he was getting he was
expecting everything whatever he wanted
he was getting so I was going the
opposite way doing the two so I was
purposely not doing a laptop yeah being
strict but again that has its own
problems because you then create a
divide between parenting and who's he
going to be drawn to who's he going to
and soft touch with mum yeah so we had
to sit down not long ago and we are now
working in a line in unison but again we
still need to find that that bonus
because I take him to because the gym
like he's so competitive which is which
is brilliant so I'm glad we've got that
side nailed down already because the
reason I put him in that school was it's
very small sports academic it's very
very and you you you win gracefully you
lose gracefully there's no such thing as
taking part there's good yeah I love
that aspect and we're going in
gymnastics on a Wednesday he swims on a
Tuesday he plays football on a Saturday
swims on a Sunday so he's doing what I
did Growing Up he doesn't sit in front
of a TV he's very active he's outside he
forests every week he's forestering
every week
um so I'm proud of that side but you're
very right in the fact that
yeah how do we uh not Molly coddle him
too much absolutely so let me give you
some insights that I've learned over the
last couple of years to do with this
stuff so
uh the number one behavioral behavioral
geneticist on the planet guy called
Robert Plowman so he was the fourth most
cited psychologist of the 20th century
that's a century that had people like
Sigmund Freud in it right so the fourth
most cited he basically has teased apart
the differences between nature and
nurture more than anybody else in
history okay every single pair of twins
born in the UK between 1991 and 1994
were enrolled into this study they've
ended up tracking I think it's somewhere
in the region of about 50 000 pairs of
twins some of these were separated at
Birth taken into adoptive or Foster
families and when you do that especially
if you've got monozygotic twins you have
one person in terms of their genes but
two environments right so it allows you
to tease apart what are the differences
etc etc when you control for everything
including socioeconomic status household
income blah blah blah blah blah the
school that you'd send your kid to
accounts for between one and three
percent of their academic outcomes so if
you were to send them to the worst
school in the region or the best school
in the region now the problem that you
have here one in three percent doesn't
sound like much another thing to fold in
is that the um
nurture part of nurturing when you raise
your kids yeah doesn't come from you and
it doesn't come from your wife okay it
comes from the friends that they hang
around with it comes from the uh father
of the cool kid that he likes to go and
play with it's like my dad's lame
because my dad doesn't play guitar but
John's dad lets him play guitar and he
gets to stay up late and have ice cream
and if John's dad also happens to be a
businessman that is very focused on
money if John's dad happens to be
someone that gambles a lot if John's dad
happens to have a terrible relationship
with his partner those are the values
that will be inculcated the single best
predictor of a child's future wealth
level when controlling for all of the
other variables is the average income of
the postcode that they grow up in so
it's the people around them the nurture
element of Nature and nurture for
children's upbringing seems to be the
friend groups that you put them in so
one of the first things that I would do
is very like and this is something that
I think about you know when I imagine my
imaginary child that I don't have yet
um I would go and vet very very closely
what are the coaches like at every
single different boxing gym swimming gym
gym gymnastics gym which is the one that
I think right he's got the values he's
the dad that's closest to me that's
closest that's what we did with that
school yeah we went to about four
private schools they were all driven by
like the education which is great for me
I was driven by the sports and the
winning side and the competitive doesn't
sound like a professional athlete all
aspects of it though but yeah so carry
on sorry no just that I I would focus
very much on
who are the other kids that are going
yeah what do the parents like that go
there I would this sounds bad but I
would very carefully vet the friends
that you're sending the kids around to
and this doesn't mean you know they can
be from any background that you want but
you want the family to have the right
values you want them to be hard working
you don't want them to be materialistic
you want them to understand the fact you
don't want them to be spending all of
their time on their phone etc etc and
um this is where
wealth doesn't create advantages for
kids yeah
um because a lot of the time if you're
rich you will Outsource raising your
kids to nannies to kindergarten etc etc
but they're not going to take this level
of uh resolution they're not going to
look at it this finally yeah and if you
do decide to do that I really think that
the difference is that you can see I I
would go as far as to say that you could
ignore the time that it looks at in
terms of school outcomes educational all
the rest of it and simply focus on do
they have the right values who are the
kids that they're hanging around with
what are the activities they're doing
outside of school and what are the
parents of the kids that they hang
around with and I think that you will
have as much if not more of an impact
now obviously you want to cover all of
the bases etc etc but that seems to be
based on what I've read one of the
longest levers that you have for your
kids and I think that you're doing it
the right way focusing on what are the
values etc etc yeah
um but yeah man it's a ruthless
situation to think that the nurture part
of Nature and nurture isn't you and it's
not your partner that's so true that is
so true so I need to make sure
everyone's around me yeah absolutely
excuse me absolutely well you know but
think about it this way man you have the
opportunity to create and I see this
again in in Austin there's a lot of
these um it's called homesteading okay
so my
friends that have sold companies for
tens of millions when they're in their
20s and are now just getting to chill
out and raise their kids on again on a
ranch or whatever they'll go and buy 100
acres of land somewhere in Texas with 10
other families one will be a doctor one
will be a teacher one will be a physical
trainer one will be something else and
they'll basically make a miniature
Village they'll homeschool the kids all
together but what they're doing is
they're pre-selecting for people that
are like the sort of people that they
like that are like the sort of people
that they want the kids to be like and
you're going to end up with those
communities I think unless there's some
like
weird uh byproduct
maladaptive social effect that happens
because they're not sufficiently exposed
to different cultures or whatever that
might be a thing but I think that you're
going to see those people having really
really great outcomes for their kids now
you might get uh like a concentration or
a distillation of
bad thought patterns because it's
focusing everything not just the good
but also the bad
um you know like this is how colds start
right it's you know if you have like a
little bit of racism and everybody
around you is a racist everybody's
pretty racist yeah yeah
um but I think that that's a good way to
look at it and what you have the
opportunity to as somebody that has a
platform that has success that has you
know an aspirational lifestyle is to not
only raise up your kid but to find other
people that have a growth mindset that
have kids and you go why don't we work
together yeah to make arcade given what
we know given how we understand that
child development works yeah why don't
we work together and dedicate the next
five to ten years to both I'm going to
give all of the values and maybe even
write it out this is something that I
consider doing sit down with you know
four other pairs of parents that have
all got kids that are all gonna maybe
have more that are around about your age
and say okay let's agree on an agenda
you know like you do with the business
you've got brand values for a business
you've got guidelines you've got a
branding guide you've got all of these
different things for a business and you
never sit down and do this for your kids
yeah yeah so I think that would be a
really good a really good strategy for
people to think about doing yeah
definitely let's uh try telling that to
my wife ah she'll be on board she'll be
on board okay so what's next what can
people expect from you next so we've got
an exciting year this year so like I say
we're talking about this on the on the
cab drive over
um I the last two years I don't know
what it was where I felt like I'd
achieved everything I wanted to other
than the Olympia and I kind of just sat
back on my Laurels a little bit I
financially got into a place I wanted to
be the companies were doing doing okay
and stuff and I kind of yeah just lulled
a bit for two years and
that's just not me and the longer I did
that for the more I was getting agitated
the more I was just not happy in myself
so this year and I said to my wife at
Christmas said look I need I need to go
back to who I am and and that's keeping
busy keeping progressing in life and
that it's not necessarily financially or
competing it's just I need to still
fulfill and keep doing things I need to
keep progressing moving forward so I
took on some big challenges this year so
again I've got a huge project which is
going to take me all year to do but this
is yeah setting me up for for the next
10 20 years and it's it's always been a
dream of mine which I've wanted to do
and it's just I've never had the right
time to do it with traveling I've been
in a different country every week and
having different obligations and stuff
but I feel like now with with the young
family and wanting to be at home more
it's a perfect time to do this so that's
as much as I'm going to say on it but
it's it's gonna be like like nothing the
UK scene so it's going to be phenomenal
and at the same time we've got the Ryan
Terry British Championship so again this
is when you're in Federation now own my
own show so it's the it's the finale I
won this in 2013 and it's the British
Championship so it's basically the best
of the best amateurs in the UK all go
head-to-head to win the British title
and you win a pro card and you go into
the pro leagues which Federation is this
this is the ifbb right uh it's
Affiliated to the ifbb but it's two Bros
but Jim shark have kindly backed me this
year so I've done it for four years
um on my own it's been very difficult
very hard and it's always just been a
passion of mine I never made money out
of it it was just because Ben Francis
swinging in last minute slip streaming
all of the work you've done exactly but
it's gonna just put bodybuilding like UK
bodybuilding back on the map and for me
that's what it's about I'm not not bored
about taking money from this at all I
just want there to be
a show where everyone goes to and just
comes out of and thinking oh my days
that's what it used to be because I grew
up around bodybuilding from 14 and I
used to go to Southport to the Mr
universities to Batley brierley Hill all
these Dives but they were just brilliant
bodybuilding shows and the standard of
of athletes the you had thousands of
people filling Village halls and stuff
and it was just brilliant and we've lost
that it became a money thing it became I
hate to say a bit political a bit clicky
and we just lost that authenticity so my
goal
taking money out of it is to bring that
back and I'm going to do everything it
takes some of the things and some of the
people who are coming to this show
already it's just going to be off the
return we've got the Manchester Arena
which we're looking at doing this
weekend with the lift event we've
actually hide that out again
um for the bodybuilding show in October
and yeah I'm so excited for that unreal
Ryan Terry ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with the
stuff that you do where should they go
yeah you can follow me on social media
Ryan J Terrier on Instagram
um that's kind of my main platform on
YouTube all that kind of stuff but yeah
well thank you for having me I
appreciate it Ryan I appreciate you
thank you mate take care
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace